as the snow melts and the City of
Buffalo counts its losses from the
blizzard stories are emerging of human
resilience and the kindness of strangers
none more so than at the church of
Pastor Al Robinson and his wife Vivian
two nights before Christmas they went to
bed with a fridge stocked with A Feast
for their nine children and five
grandchildren my wife and I are thinking
ah just another Buffalo snowstorm you
know uh we're used to getting a couple
feet but soon they began to hear of
neighbors who had lost power of people
freezing to death in their homes they
opened their doors to those seeking
Refuge more than 100 people turned up
sleeping on mattresses all over the
church and even in the couple's own
living quarters we were doing breakfast
lunch dinner and snacks we had I had to
pick up an 84 year old woman on my
shoulders carry her to the bathroom
others had already developed frostbite
by the time they arrived they got so
cold where that the upper layer of their
skin here started bubbling like
blistering like a burn like a third
degree burn if we didn't open these
doors you would have catastrophic losses
we had people from Detroit Michigan
stuck over here we had people from
Niagara Falls stuck in this neighborhood
there were so many people stuck in this
surrounding area that there were not
even an outlet for them to go to and we
were also told that emergency services
would not be available for the storm the
blizzard of 2022 has reignited the Deep
economic and racial inequalities in
Buffalo more than half of the 38 people
who died were black or hispanic most
from the poverty-stricken east side of
the city tragedy he's no stranger here
just seven months ago 10 people were
shot dead in this supermarket in a
racially motivated attack well I was
here
um
20 minutes before
the gunman came in Michael Martin says
his community feels persecuted once more
This Time by Decades of neglect with
this storm
we had nothing
so you know some of the corner stores
but they're being inundated with people
it's a bit of a food desert yeah a food
desert losing out you know fellow
neighbors here and then losing
what over 40 people with the blizzard so
it's quite a traumatizing few months
yeah it has been because I had like 10
people in my house and two rooms for my
store was electric so I had to use
propane to heat my house
uh I had my kids in there and
I just had to make sure that they had
heat you know because I got a 11 month
old grandbaby there many people were
surprised by the ferocity of this storm
some unprepared but there's no escaping
that certain people in this city bore
the brunt of its brutality Martha
Kellner Sky News Buffalo